Join me explore the multiverse
and ask the question what if
everybody knows how iron man became iron man
how cap became cat the fun twist is that we
go in different directions and what does that
look like and it's like wait what what if as
a concept and as a comic book is something
that would always come up in conversation
it was almost like it was marvel's twilight zone
for our show we're not borrowing anything that
was pre-done in the comic we're riffing on the
marvel movie cinematic version of those characters
that's what's wonderful about this what
if concept anything can be explored
what if ultron won what if thor was
never banished what happens next
when brian and brad pitched the
notion of using norman rockwell
as a basis for the style of the show i mean that's
that's my bread and butter i love that stuff
it's pretty exciting when you see it all come
together that's some of the best storytelling
we've ever had what if gives us a whole new idea
of what the physical reality of the universe is
that is something that's going to be explored
in other ways moving forward in our films
i really believe that deepening fictional
mythologies is a way to appreciate them
more as a way to to understand them more look at
them in a different way and they've got now two
seasons of what if uh ideas underway that that
some of the best storytelling we've ever had
and you may see spin into other into other mediums
but is really the most uniquely beautiful animated
series i've seen a long time obviously you
can spin out any number of what-if stories
and it's exciting to do so but you're
searching for that central thread that could
make it feel like essential viewing for the mcu
and what emerged was the relationship between
captain carter and the watcher which is
something that that evolves uh in a in a grand
fashion in the second season of the show
Welcomeback everyone happy comic-con week this will be
my what if season 2 teaser trailer video they
released a first look at the series they explain
what the episodes are going to be they showed off
some of the characters so we'll break it all down
if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the episodes of course i'll
do videos for all the episodes just like i did for
season one they also dropped teaser trailers for
spider-man freshman year in x-men 97 like the
x-men revival series i'll do separate videos
for that later today too but what if season 2
is supposed to begin with what if peggy carter
fought the hydra stomper is basically picking up
right where season one left off with that post
credit scene with their version of captain america
winter soldier but the peggy carter captain carter
fighting steve rogers as the hydro stomper
his version of the winter soldier basically
in a very iron man mark one inspired giant suit
they actually showed off the entire first episode
at the panel like right at the end of the panel
but they showed off a bunch of different shows
like i said the x-men show the marvel zombie show
the spider-man freshman year show don't worry i
will do videos about all the footage from all
the different series but the rest of the what if
season 2 trailer is just filled with appearances
by recognizable characters like three spider-mans
recreating the moment from no way home on the
statue of liberty so they do have an episode
inspired by the events of spider-man no way home
with tom holland spider-man fighting with tobey
maguire spider-man and andrew garfield spider-man
they said that they would be trading a lot more
heavily on marvel phase four events and like the
really big wtf moments we've seen in the movies
the last couple years so far so of course they're
going to include a bunch of that stuff too they
also showed off footage of a marvel 1602 episode
if you haven't read that series it's meant to be
an alternate universe set in the past of the year
1602 with basically versions of all the characters
but done in this really old timey way in the
1600s they also had an episode with the shangshi
characters fighting odin in the asgardians there
was a crazy mad max fury road looking episode like
a race episode with valkyrie's character they also
did confirm that they would do the episode that
they had to delete from season one basically like
they had to drop the episode after they'd already
been working on it for a while with iron man
and gamora on sakaar fighting thanos but right
now the plan is for them to do 10 episodes like
they were originally going to do during season 1.
there were just some delays because of the
virus that's why there were only nine episodes
the tenth episode was the missing iron man
episode of him being stuck on sakhar it was
basically them giving the plot of thor ragnarok
to iron man and combining it with the first half
of avengers infinity war with thanos going around
collecting all the infinity stones that's why when
they were forming the guardians of the multiverse
during the finale you saw that quick sequence with
gamora to explain how she got thanos armor and
his weapon and then wound up on the guardians
of the multiverse the reason why iron man is in
that junk looking version of an iron man hulk
hulkbuster suit is because somehow he wound up
getting sent to sakaar instead of the hulk and
while he was there just like thor had to fight the
contest of champions against the hulk iron man had
to fight against gamora but because he's iron man
he built himself an iron man suit dumpster diving
because it's basically a trash planet so he
built himself a hulk buster out of trash call it
the trash buster but the idea was that after they
fight a little bit they come together they team up
and then wind up creating the infinity crusher
device to destroy that universe's version of the
infinity stones they also talk during this about
how the watchers relationship is going to evolve
with captain carter and the other characters as
well that like new version of guardians of the
multiverse that they put together the other really
cool thing if you're looking for clues on episodes
if you look in the background of this promo here
you look at their whiteboard there's actually 11
episodes that they have up there like what is this
mystery 11th episode we thought there were 10 they
wheeled it down to 9. so like they're two missing
episodes but i'm assuming some of these ideas that
are on the whiteboard just got pushed to season
two it says maria and the cree save carol danvers
which is probably meant to be what if maria rambo
was saved by the cree instead of carol danvers in
service of doing a big reference to the monica
rambo version of captain marvel the original
female captain marvel in the comics maria rambo
is monica rambo's mother and in this version of
events assuming maria rambo who was carol danvers
fellow test pilot was just the one to fly the
test mission with the faster than light tesseract
engine that mar-vell was building mean that she's
the one that got shot down in the crash and then
rescued by yawn rog in the creek and would wind up
getting a version of a captain marvel origin story
just flipping the roles but even cooler underneath
this designated as episode vii is titled
1988 avengers i think that's just meant to be
what if the avengers formed during 1988 earlier
in the timeline who would have been on that team
just for reference tony stark would have been 18
at the time so he still would have been finishing
at mit he graduated mit really young howard stark
would still be in his early 70s pretty old but
still alive to work with the team like an old man
iron man but you notice how much they talk about
daredevil what if stories silver surfer infinity
gauntlet stories there's a lot of fantastic four
in here too just because the watcher comes from
the fantastic four comics so they spend a lot of
this talking about fantastic four characters
there's a ghostwriter what if story in there
a shangshi what if story even a galactus what
if story they do clarify that they're not doing
any direct comic book adaptations from the
wedded comics like they're not doing a copy
paste version of any of the comic book what-if
stories they're just riffing on some of those
ideas and using mcu characters to do it and when
kevin feige talks about seeing the characters
show up in other mediums he's talking about these
animated what-if characters from other universes
showing up in the live-action marvel projects
like live-action marvel disney plus series and
live-action marvel movies best example that was a
version of captain carter showing up in the live
action doctor strange too but the funny thing is
on the what if season 2 panel the producers were
very clear that like oh that wasn't our version of
captain carter it was just a version very similar
to her our captain carter wouldn't go out that
quickly against a version of wanda like that so
even they were kind of clowning on how quickly
scarlet witch took out the illuminati characters
the doctor two strange writers and producers
also said that sinister strange was inspired by
supreme strange the version that we saw
during what if but obviously they were
meant to be different characters as well too
like sinister strange was not the version
that we saw during what if but talking more
about season two characters coming back doctor
strange supreme is still probably one of the most
important characters to come out of season one
the big difference with them going into season two
from season one is that they were actually writing
all the season one episodes before they knew about
what was happening during the marvel phase four
projects which is why you don't see like alligator
loki running around during what if season one the
advantage now is when they were writing all the
scripts they knew what was happening during marvel
phase four so they can incorporate new characters
from the newer marvel phase 4 movies and disney
plus series they talked about doing characters
from the shangshi movie eternals characters
obviously they know what happens to spider-man no
way home and they can do spider-man characters but
they'll also know about thor love and thunder
black panther 2 guardians of the galaxy 3 along
with elena bulova from the black widow movie who's
now the de facto main black widow of the mcu in
present day and like i said all the loki variants
alligator loki tva loki mobius renslayer kang he
who remains even what happened during one division
billy and tommy white vision john walker us agent
the new falcon version of captain america val
madame hydra the contessa all them will eventually
start showing up during what-if episodes either
season 2 season 3 and because this teaser just
features so much ghost rider daredevil silver
surfer fantastic four stuff even galactus stuff
part of what they explain is the limit on their
series is they can only do characters that have
already shown up in the series and in the movies
so far deadpool would also be an easy slam dunk
too so eventually deadpool will show up in the
what if series just because he's tailor made for
that kind of stuff so everyone let me know in
the comments which new characters from marvel
phase 4 do you want to see show up during season
2 and what kind of stories do you want them to do
what'll happen though is my next big trailer video
will be my spider-man freshman year teaser trailer
i'll post that later today make sure you enable
alerts for my channel so you don't miss that
also do a separate video for the marvel zombies
teaser trailer that'll post in the next couple
of days as well there's going to be a bunch of
trailers tomorrow too i'll probably also try
to do a teaser trailer video for x-men 97 if i do
that'll post early saturday morning tomorrow we're
probably going to get the black panther 2 trailer
there might be a new she-hulk trailer 2 because
that series is only a couple weeks away before
premiering will you wait for everything everyone
click here for my black panther 2 trailer video
i'll update the link as soon as i post that and
you can click here for my spider-man freshman year
teaser trailer video i'll update the link as soon
as i post that too thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and happy comic-con week!